music
[Music]
[Music]
this conference has been recorded
conference registry
uh hi everyone thanks for joining us in
progress
uh my name is dylan robertson i'm the
ottawa bureau chief for the winnipeg
free press
we've got our panelists here today
they'll be joining us
and this time around we're going to get
each of them to introduce themselves
when they start to speak
and then we'll throw to questions
afterwards
we'll use the raise hand function on
zoom
to take the priority questions for the
gallery first before the other ones and
i understand that we have a hard stop
for 3 pm today so could the first
speaker please start and introduce
themselves
before i begin i would like to welcome
dr teresa tan chief public health
officer
and ms laura
from the canadian pediatric society
thank you all for being with us today
to talk about
and reiterate the importance of staying
up to date with your vaccinations
keeping your vaccination up to date is
the key to continuing to protect
yourself your family and your loved ones
vaccinations save lives which is why
safe effective vaccines are now
available for everyone in canada over
six months of age
and booster doses are available for
everyone over the age of five
this morning health canada authorized
the use of the modernist bike facts
19 vaccine as a booster dose in adults
aged 18 years or over
a bivalent vaccine is one that targets
two different strains of a virus
the vaccine authorized today
19 vaccine to be authorized for use in
where possible
we will
these vaccines will be distributed
to the provinces and territories we
repeat this in english
this morning
health canada authorized the use of the
moderna bivalent koviz 19 vaccine as a
booster dose in adults aged 18 years or
over
a bivalent vaccine is one that targets
two different strains of a virus
the vaccine authorized today targets
both the original strain of kobe 19 and
the omicron strain
it is the first bivalent kobin-19
vaccine to be authorized for use in
canada
as we also heard this morning the
national advisory committee on
immunization also known as nasi
continues to recommend a booster this
fall
where possible for those 18 or older
that those should be a bi-valence
booster
that targets omicron like the one that
has been authorized today
this being said
all vaccines approved until now continue
to remain safe and effective
in addition
780 000 doses of that new bivalent
vaccine will be delivered to canada
tomorrow
a total of 10.5 million doses will be
delivered by the end of september
as usual these vaccines will be
delivered quickly and free of charge to
provinces and territories
let me also speak about the importance
of this false vaccination campaign
this fall will be challenging with the
return of the flu and other respiratory
diseases
and people moving indoor
canada has been ahead of all other g7
countries and most other countries in
the world in terms of two-dose
vaccination
ninety percent of all the adults in
canada have received two doses
but only sixty percent of adult
canadians have received a third dose
putting us behind all other g7 countries
except for the united states
canada's public health
estimates that if we update again if we
increase from 60 to 90
canadians who are up to date with their
vaccination status we could reduce by up
to 90 percent
the level of hospitalizations linked to
covid by the end of fall or the
beginning of winter
support
vaccine protection is like a phone
battery
it needs to be recharged from time to
time
recharging our protection after six
months is important
otherwise we are left without the power
to protect ourselves and our loved ones
of our
we need to take
and to safely maintain our level of
protection by staying up to date with
our immunizations
and if it has been six months or more
since our last vaccination well it is
time to get a booster
getting everyone caught up with a
vaccination is a top priority
this is not only for true for covet 19
vaccinations but also for routine
vaccinations for all children and adults
mercy thank you migrate
and i will now turn i believe to dr tom
mercilem
thank you mr minister hello everyone it
has been as has been mentioned the vast
majority of canadians have received two
doses of covet-19 vaccine and many
adults have received a booster however
we know that covet-19 immunity decreases
over time and protection from a vaccine
or infection that was given more than
six months ago no longer provides
optimal protection
being up to date with your vaccine is
very important to near azure
survivor your vaccinations up to date
including a booster dose
offers the best protection against 19.
as fall approaches
although 19 activity is declining in
many areas
the virus continues to circulate across
canada
as people begin to spend more time
indoors
we expect to see an increase in covet 19
activity
canadians have received their primary
series and kept up to date with boosters
have a very strong foundation of
protection the new bivalent booster
which includes the original strain of
the sars cov2virus and the ba1
subvariant of the omicron lineage will
help build on that protection
we know that the modena spikevac
bivalent vaccine also generates a good
immune response against the ba4 and ba5
subvariance currently circulating
if it has been six months or longer
since your last dose or since being
infected it's time to get a booster dose
it is especially important if you're at
high risk for severe illness from covert
19.
where possible for those age 18 years or
older that dose should be a bivalent
booster that is specifically targeting
omicron
for adolescents 12 to 17 years of age at
higher risk of severe outcomes for covet
19 the booster may also be a virulent
vaccine
however if the bivalent booster is not
readily available an original mrna kova
19 vaccine should be offered to ensure
timely protection
both the original and bivalent covet 19
vaccines are effective as a booster
the simple message is having up-to-date
vaccination is the key priority to
restore protection that wanes over time
so the booster that is available to you
is better than not being up to date with
your vaccine protection
we know that involving communities and
ensuring they have the credible
information and tools they need to help
increase vaccine uptake will be key to
successful full vaccination campaigns
the public health agency of canada will
continue to support health care
providers and community organizations
including providing funding for
innovative projects to make information
accessible and boost vaccine confidence
i would now like to turn the floor over
to dr laura
pediatric infectious disease specialist
with the canadian pediatric society
we'll talk about the importance of
immunization especially as children
return to school
and engage in more indoor activities
thank you
thank you very much dr tam
as dr tam mentioned i'm a pediatric
infectious disease specialist who works
in british columbia caring for children
with complicated infections
this last two and a half years has been
really challenging for many children and
families
and importantly many children have
gotten behind on their regular routine
vaccinations
more and more we see things getting back
to normal
and with that unfortunately we're going
to expect to see the more common
infections that we haven't seen much of
over the last two years like influenza
are going to be coming back
and becoming more frequent again
but we've also noticed that we've seen
reports about cases of polio in
countries that haven't seen polio for
many years this reminds us that for all
vaccine preventable diseases they can
come back if we don't stay on top of our
regular routine immunizations we're far
better off preventing infections and
keeping children healthy in the first
place than treating infections that have
happened
while we can't protect children against
every single infection that's out there
by making sure that kids are up to date
with their routine vaccines we can
prevent many of the most common and most
severe infections
immunization is one of the most
important ways that we can keep children
healthy and vaccines are very safe and
there are very rarely reasons not to get
vaccinated
as many of us know some of the most
important
effects of health effects of the
pandemic on children in canada have
actually been the mental health
developmental and educational impacts
especially so for children youth and
families who face structural and
psychosocial barriers
to accessing care and activities even
before the pandemic
it's going to be really important as we
go into the fall that in order to
balance safety with
maximizing connection time in school and
friends with peer time with friends and
peers
that children
are vaccinated both
with a regular routine vaccine but also
with the covid19 vaccine the canadian
pediatric society and pediatricians
family physicians and infectious disease
doctors from across the country all
strongly recommend that children get
caught up with all vaccines
including the covid18 vaccine that of
course is now available for children
from six months and up
some families do have important
questions about how vaccines work and
how we can make sure that they are safe
and it's important if you do have
questions talk to a trusted health care
provider about these questions whether
that's a family doctor a pediatrician a
public health nurse or another provider
they can often answer your questions
really well
and i'd really like to thank
the minister and dr tam for having me
here today to talk a little bit more
about why
routine vaccines as well as covid
vaccines are important
theaters
we have about 45 minutes for questions
from journalists
you'll have one question one follow-up
we'll start with the only question
please use the raise hand function we'll
prioritize press gallery members and
we'll alternate english and french and
when you ask a question please specify
whom your question is for
me
from canada
no my question is foreign
this vaccine is superior to the current
vaccine even though the current vaccines
are already very good
but we have seen
in
studies
is more effective against omicron
also
a lot of canadians
have waited to the end of the summer
beginning of the fall to get their
booster and be up to date
we've heard that
summer
is not the greatest time
to be concerned with vaccines but with
the return to school and the return to
work we know that people want to protect
themselves
and because of what we
went through in the last two years
it has been very important for everyone
so people want to be up to date with
their immunizations
and they have the possibility now to get
an even better vaccine and this will
allow a lot of canadians to make the
right choice
and to get vaccinated and if i can
summarize again one of the results
that i saw over the past few days
created by
the canada public health agency
we talk a lot about
importance
pressure
and they will see this
as
other
the number of hospitalizations
by the end of fall and the beginning of
2023.
the cases are going down we feel like
we're perhaps between two waves people
might be wondering if it might be time
to remove certain restrictions for
example wearing a mask on trains and
planes
perhaps as well
random testing at airports is this still
going to be part of your plans for now
the goal is to make everything as
seamless as
possible
even though we believe that omicron is
less serious
there were more deaths this summer than
in previous summers and more hospital
hospitalizations in summer 2022
thirdly
we know
in order to continue protecting
the nurses
and the health care workers who need our
help next up is nick boiver cbc
good afternoon a question for uh
minister duklow um people in the us are
soon going to be having access to um
vaccines that target va four and five uh
here in canada those uh we apparently
have not even been submitted for
approval with health canada uh can you
just explain
whether the government could have done
more why that communication maybe didn't
happen with the with modern and pfizer
and why we seem to now be a bit behind
the u.s
uh i would uh
very quickly switch uh turn to dr tam
who may have
more up-to-date information on the
process regarding pfizer i can tell you
that regarding moderna
the announcement
in the u.s took place a day ago so we
are almost simultaneously
announcing the same decision in addition
to that we are going to receive the
vaccines tomorrow uh 780 000 vaccine in
the country tomorrow and we have a very
solid delivery uh scheduled for
september 210.5 million doses where of
modena will arrive in the next few weeks
so we are solidly
ready for the fall vaccination campaign
that's because of two things first
because we have had
a great relationship with uh all
pharmaceutical companies including uh
modern obviously which is leading to
today's announcement and second because
we have been working alongside the uh
independent obviously uh approval
process of health canada we have worked
independently with procurement and
public and
pspc procurement canada so that
very soon tomorrow in fact we'll be
receiving the delivery of these new
doses and provinces and territories will
be able to start
vaccinating with the new biovalent
vaccines probably as early as next week
dr tom would you want to speak more uh
directly to
what you know about the approval process
for other vaccines knowing that this is
not the responsibility of p hack it's
managed by
the independent regulators at health
canada
yes uh messi womenist
um yes i could um um expand on the
answer i think the really important
thing to remember is that we now have um
potentially a range of bivalent vaccines
and they include the omicron uh spike
protein so
what we have uh that health canada
approved and authorized does contain an
omicron strain
the u.s has a slightly different uh
variety of that but
these updated or adapted vaccines uh are
there to provide a broadened protection
against different variants
and are therefore expected to help
maintain optimal protection against
covet 19.
um i am very confident in our health
canada
the colleagues and regulars process
could have actually reviewed clinical
data
from the manufacturer that demonstrated
that
the immune response that's elicited
is better it's superior
using this bivalent vaccine
against the original strain the ba1
ba2ba4 and ba5
um just to comment on the fact that our
contractual processes once um health
canada receives submission and i believe
that
you know some of these submissions are
anticipated very shortly um including
ba45 is that our
advanced messaging agreement does
provide flexibility to access new
formulations when approved and available
um how do you and maybe this is a
question for uh for dr tam
how do you manage the messaging the
public health messaging to the public
when we do know we just heard it from
you now and from dr sharma this morning
that the country is expecting to to get
applications for more up-to-date
vaccines in the just the coming weeks
um
how do you prevent people from hearing
that expecting you know perhaps maybe
they'll want to wait until the the most
up-to-date vaccine is available i mean
what do you do to make sure that people
get this vaccine that's now been
approved instead of waiting for what
apparently is coming
but the important thing is timely
vaccination
and that the best protections you get is
to get your booster as soon as possible
and so waiting longer
it takes has a certain risk
and as minister duklow has said that
based on our modeling data if you wait
too long the impact of the boosted dose
is reduced
and so getting ahead of the four
resurgence is very important
and as i've said um in my opening
remarks that even the current vaccine
provides good protection um against
particularly severe outcomes and a
boosted dose will enhance that so this
bivalent omicron vaccine uses a spike
that is quite different already from the
original strain and this bivalent
vaccine
provides good
immunogenicity
in a clinical trial so i think the
message is get up to date get your
booster if you haven't had
anything uh in terms of vaccination or
infection in the last six months
we cannot hear you
okay uh we're going to go on to laura
osmond from the canadian press
good afternoon uh thanks for taking our
questions
i wanted to ask you we're hearing from
the provinces that they're expecting the
very first deliveries of this new
bivalent vaccine to be somewhat limited
so they're going to be beginning with
um those most at risk i'm wondering
again
to build on my colleagues question um
people are likely not just waiting for
the next version of the vaccines to be
8.5 but how long do you expect them to
wait for the
currently approved the ba 0.1
multivalent vaccine do you have a sense
of when there will be enough vaccine in
the country that
the average non
sort of non-immuno-compromised person
might be able to get their hands on one
thank you uh laura and the short answer
is that supply is not an issue
we are going to receive tomorrow 780 000
vaccines of the bivalent type
just to give you an order of magnitude
in the last few weeks
we have
seen about 200 000 vaccinations per week
so
200 000 on average in the last few weeks
780 000 delivered tomorrow to canada and
obviously quickly send to provinces and
territories in a total of 10.5 million
in september 10.5 million is
approximately 30 of the adult population
which is enough to bridge the 60 to 90
gap as i mentioned earlier and with the
additional doses coming later and with
the doses already
available we have ample
supply to vaccinate
all
all the canadians that want to be
vaccinated in the short and in the
longer term
the issue is how easy
from a physical
perspective it will be for people to
access the vaccination facility so that
depends on the information that people
can have access to
the
vaccinators the people the
workers that we'll need to find in
different provinces and territories for
vaccination to take place so if both
information ease of access
from proximity to where people live how
to reach
more
vulnerable or more marginalized
communities who need
more better information and sometimes
just little help for them to to find it
easy
and appropriate to get the protection
that they need and that they deserve so
it's more of a
human resource worker challenge that is
significant for problems and territories
if we
want in the next week
to administer the 10.5 million by
available doses that we'll be receiving
in september
thank you so much um i wanted to ask you
as well you mentioned our comparatively
poor uh
booster rates uh for people getting a
third dose you mentioned in the summer
earlier this summer that the federal
government was going to be trying to
work on some campaigns to convince
people to get boosted
what can we expect to see now that these
biovalent doses are going to start to
arrive to encourage people to actually
get them
a
national
campaign will start next week
the uh
the
the title is
protection wanes action is required just
like a phone battery your phone battery
no
winds no needs to be recharged for your
back for your phone to work to have
appropriate power to operate and for
your vaccination protection to be
affected so you recharge your phone
battery by
plugging it to the
electricity you recharge your vaccine
protection by taking action and getting
vaccination no protection so that's
going to start next week this is
obviously a national campaign we know
that provinces and territories will
continue to increase their efforts at
reaching to people speaking in terms
that
inform and sometimes reassure them with
community leaders with health care uh
experts
like uh
dr solvay and many others so it's it's
it's a big team effort uh we are
obviously there to support the efforts
of with integrity or is it supporting
those efforts will be key
in linking the people to the vaccines
uh raphael we we can't hear you i'm can
you try once more please
okay don't say uh
[Music]
new deliveries that will be arriving
shortly
what will happen
with
the
vaccines
targeted the original strain
what will we be doing to
avoid
wasting
a significant amount of vaccines
there are countries
who are less advanced in their
vaccination status
share with countries
and so it will be an option to share
these very effective vaccines with these
countries in the coming months
for the other ones we'll store them
adequately so there is no waste
question
thank you and i imagine we'll hear
more
on distribution in the coming weeks
and about how additional vaccines will
be shared with other countries
with you on
distribution that has been done in the
past weeks and months
oliver with ctv news
hi there thank you for taking our
questions my first question is just
about the interval online it says that
the new by valen vaccine can be given
out after four months but i believe dr
tam was saying after six so when exactly
do you recommend getting this new shot
after either finishing
your primary series of vaccine getting
covered or having a booster
yes
um yeah thank you for the question so
with um our national advisory committee
on immunization we wanted to
consolidate the various recommendations
and make it simple and that is if you
haven't had a booster
or been infected um within a six-month
time frame it's time to get your booster
of course though that interval can be
adjusted um but we we don't advise going
down uh below three months
um i think
if people want to get the new bivalen
vaccine you get an opportunity to do
that with within a sort of female time
frame especially if you're at high risk
and
so so it's actually quite important
because we
there's there's even more recent data
published about the success of the uh
nasty recommendations on the intervals
to date
and um it's um it it won't give you as
much benefit if you went down below
three months so that's a sort of time
period that provinces as they implement
their programs uh will be working with
uh but just remember the six months you
haven't had a booster within that six
month time frame
it's been longer than that please go and
get a booster
okay thank you for that clarification
and my follow-up
the health minister as well as dr tam
you both mentioned that it's going to be
a tough fall and so given that i'm
wondering what you think about ontario's
decision to remove isolation
requirements for anybody who tests
positive for cope at 19.
well i can start and then invite dr tan
to uh provide
the more policy scientific
uh basis for how p hack assesses the
public health measures but obviously as
a health minister i
value and support very much the
importance of my colleagues in different
provinces and territories to make
decisions which they believe to be the
most appropriate ones at their level in
their conditions and with the experience
and expertise that they have accumulated
over the last few months so it always
always always be important for me to
recognize that their decisions are
anchored in their knowledge and ability
to to to to work and to serve the best
to their to their the best possibly
their their constituents in different
provinces and territories but dr tam you
may want to add or may not need to add
anything to that
yes thank you for the question i think i
always advocate for the vaccine plus
approach which vaccine forms have found
a key foundational layer of protection
but please consider layering on masks
staying home if you're sick
and of course
maximize ventilation optimize it as much
as you can i think on the and then the
key layer of staying home with sick is
what ontario is trying to implement
i would just say that from a factual you
know scientific basis people have to
remember
that if you get infected you can still
shed the virus
for quite a number of days
and it could be as long as 10 days
so you've got to really be careful even
if you're leaving um
your home
leaving isolation if you know you've
been infected
take all other layers of precaution wear
mask especially if you're going to be in
contact with others and they're at high
risk
we say third time is the charm and with
that of yeah
thank you everyone thank you for your
patience
and thank you minister zuckerberg
my question has to do with the random
testing some people have been receiving
their results
after the test
this is especially true for people who
take
the test to do at home
about 40 of people who are receiving
their tests late do you see this as a
failure for the program
i know that it's supposed to help with
the detection of variance
is there perhaps an issue with the
execution of this program
thank you and
congratulations rafael on being able to
connect to the call
um as you mentioned
it is important to understand the goal
of this program
it is not
to offer individual tests it's to
understand
importation of the virus that we're
having in canada it's not to tell people
if they are covet positive or negative
it is
important data
for
the public health agency
it allows
where they're coming
their individual results
if people are sick they will generally
use a rapid test to find out
if they are sick or not these rapid
tests are easily accessible in
pharmacies and so people have
for their individual circumstances to
find out if they are infected or not and
they can act accordingly
dr tam if you have anything to add you
may do so now
you gave a very good answer thank you
thank you very much
the public health agency wants to test
five thousand people per day
is there
a
[Music]
the cost benefit yes
but 5 000 tests per day
are there any other means to do so for
example waste water detection
which allows us
well it's not necessarily through that
measure that we're going to stop them
from coming in
beneficial
cost to benefit assessment
is this something that you might examine
for the fall
answer
that's an excellent question
a little more perhaps than i should and
then i'll give the floor to dr tam but
if you
give me a minute
the government and the costs for people
who are being tested even though it is
only a few people that
get tested they do need to take the time
to do it so it is a part of the social
costs that the agency needs to take into
account
that said
there aren't
many other ways
to proceed
in order to have
data on where people
because even if we're
making progress
waste water
data
this is a method
does not um
give us data that is us specific
data coming from
people entering canada
and before giving the floor to dr tam
i would like to say that public health
agency is trying to work
more closely with other countries
they are also
developing
alternatives to
pcr
and that's why we need to increase our
collaboration because there are
more people traveling between these
countries
and canada
and this can lean
to the importation of
covet 19 and we want to better
understand
everything so that we can react better
and knowing more about the countries of
origin
is important for us
on the work currently being done
by the agency
which is important work
to examine the costs and the advantages
of the
[Music]
different ways to follow the importation
of covet 19 in canada
thank you again
you
gave a very comprehensive response
in my view
and to modify public health measures
[Music]
poor detective we need between 4 000 and
5 000 cases to detect
significant variance
and we need
information on the country of origin
[Music]
[Music]
it is not currently
possible to use this system
to have information on the country of
origin for example
it's difficult to do to get that data
from an airport
with waste water for example
it's hard to know
which
[Music]
there are a lot of people who go through
an airport so
that system is
not robust enough
to give us
all the data that we need
but
[Music]
whether or not it is
a method that should be continued 15
minutes and six questions so we'll try
to hit up as many as we can next up is
marsha mcleod with the globe and mail
hi there thanks for taking our questions
my question is from minister duklow you
said a few minutes ago that canada and
the us
are quote almost simultaneously
announcing the same decision regarding
these um violent vaccines the u.s has
announced the availability of the
vaccine targeting the ba-4 and ba-5
sub-variants and we've approved
obviously the ba1 targeted version could
you just clarify what you meant saying
you know we've made the same decision as
as the us
well first the same decision on moderna
uh one day apart uh second as uh dr tam
will make even more clear in a moment
now those
that both by availing vaccines all
target umicron omicron is a family now
of sub-variants
which resemble each other and are quite
different from the original
wuhan strain so that's why
they
they share this in similarity
like different brothers of the same
family the omicron family very very much
related in terms of the
the actual biological structure so all
of that means that
those different type of bivalent
vaccines all related to omicron share
lots of similar things but for that to
be more precise let me turn back to dr
tam
yes um i think every country is trying
their hardest to update the um current
vaccines and we are actually quite
aligned for example with the european uh
decisions the ema made their
announcements today um on uh the va one
uh
omicron bivalent vaccine uh very very
similar to us as well and i think uh the
united kingdom and others uh have gone
in the same path
um i think we're always interested in
our american colleagues and their data
and what has been submitted to them but
we have to make sure that health canada
received the information and that go
through the rigorous process what i can
say is that we do have clinical
information
from moderna for the omicron
containing updated vaccine which shows
that the immune response in the people
vaccinated
shows a good immune response to ba4 and
ba5 as well
thank you and just as a follow-up um
when could canadians expect to see a
bivalent vaccine that specifically
targets ba4
and ba5 here in canada
i think of course we have to let health
canada do their job the company has to
submit and we believe that's um will be
quite soon there's a submissions but it
is the companies that have to do that
and health canada colleagues are in a
very close communication with the fda
certainly right now finding out more
about
the decision making
and
the data that they have to make that
decision and just uh to emphasize so
that in the
nasty our national advisory committee on
immunization already made the
recommendation at the same time as
health canada
authorized the vaccine
in the united states they are still
deliberating i think through their nasty
equivalent exactly what the
recommendations would be and that's
happening right now
next up is adam miller with cbc
my question
how effective do you think the ba1 by
valent vaccines will be against
transmission particularly
of the dominant ba4 and ba-5 variants
you know in the real world based on the
available data you've seen
um we do not know what the real world
impact is because
that wasn't is not available we in the
modern vaccine we know from the uh
clinical information of the people
vaccinated in the
clinical trials that the neutralizing
antibody um boos is quite
significant
um certainly it's it's the level of the
neutralizing antibodies boosted against
the original strain ba1
ba2 ba four and five so that's a good
range of coverage
it is possible that as more data becomes
available we'll see some difference
between these um
these different types of updated
vaccines but we don't have that yet but
i think you brought up a really good
point in that uh what they may in fact
boost is the with the level of
neutralizing antibodies is the
protection at least for a period of time
maybe through the four months
a protection against infection and
transmission so that we hope to see will
be boosted
okay and um thanks for that and my
follow-up question
is you know i asked dr knew this morning
what our plan is moving forward with
these vaccines i guess my question for
you is what will happen with the
original coveted vaccines when canada
switches over to these violent bivalent
vaccines are they going to expire will
they still have some use in the future
and um yeah
what exactly
are we going to see you know happen with
these original vaccines
um should i take that first minister the
club yes please do so
yes so i think
the national variety community on
immunization essentially is advising
that the new bivalent booster
is provided to people 18 plus and also
12 to 17 years if they're high risk
medical conditions so i think that with
the quite a large supply of vaccines
coming on board in september that switch
will occur
throughout this month
so it is important to minimize wastage
and as much as possible
if we don't need the vaccine of course
not to acquire more of it and to be able
to provide it if it's useful to others
but it does mean that some of them
likely won't be used and but we do still
have to minimize
any potential wastage
and i would add to that very briefly
that
no avoiding as much as possible wastage
is clearly a key objective
at the same time we want to be certain
that canadians have access the best
vaccines possible i spoke earlier about
the the
potential and hopefully probable impact
on hospitalization that our vaccination
campaign in the fall may have
just to give you a number
uh on average uh
some
some
hospitalizations you the kobe 19 cost
about 23 000
23 000
is obviously a lot a lot of money but in
addition to that no
our health care system and our health
care workers are burdened with with kobe
19 and many other
issues so vaccination has been key and
will remain a key tool
in protecting canadians so although we
will at all costs avoid wastage we will
make sure that canadians have access to
the best possible vaccines so they can
protect themselves and protect others
uh we've got seven minutes we'll try to
get as many as we can next up is alex
boyd with the toronto star
hi there thanks for taking questions uh
we've heard a lot today obviously about
having to keep our vaccines updated as
we go ontario scrapping their isolation
policy uh wondering if these are signs
that we are now treating the pandemic
more as endemic and if so how that
changes the management approach at the
federal level could we see some of these
restrictions begin to phase out
federally as well
well there are two components to that
first whether
19 is becoming endemic and i'll turn and
we'll turn to that in a moment to dr tam
and second uh what
for more what policies could be changed
at the federal level on that second
point
as you've seen over the last few months
and as you will see within the next few
weeks depending on the situation we
always adjust our policies based on
what we know but also on the prudential
approach to the management of corvid 19
which has helped save
tens of thousands of lives and hundreds
of thousands of hospitalizations
compared to
what we would have seen had the pandemic
been managed differently but on the
science part let me turn to dr khan
yes i mean i think there's lots of ways
that people want to define what an
endemic state is and some of it includes
what is it now getting into a more
predictable pattern
is the r
level the the reproduction number just
hovering around one there's all these
different kind of ways of thinking about
it
and is it more manageable
but i think
i would prefer to think about as
certainly ongoing management of this
virus it is not leaving the human
population anytime soon
i
the summer wave tells us that it's not
entirely predictable you know we can't
just say
we expect it every year in a certain
period of time in the winter
and
and then prepare for that kind of
ongoing management
it may settle down i think it would be
nice to have another look at that after
this fall
and then
of course the next months will let us
know whether the virus is becoming more
predictable
at the same time as moving towards that
state of ongoing management some of it
is not really scientific it's about how
to get everyone in canada into thinking
about
managing to
deal with the virus and indeed other
viruses
by taking up regular habits so regularly
updating the vaccine regularly wearing a
mask as needed based on viral activities
in the community these personal
protective habits
is what we would want to develop and and
we can we again reinforce that over the
fall and winter months
[Music]
thank you uh next up is uh karen
mckinley from the brandon sun
uh good afternoon
and actually this is more about fourth
dose we're talking a lot about boosters
but um
in terms of manitoba they were
uh back in july they said they were not
going to open up eligibility for fourth
dose until the bivalent vaccine
may or may not become available now that
it's here
we're still waiting on word if they're
going to open up um
eligibility but just considering all the
messaging we've heard about getting your
booster as quickly as possible does that
apply to also people who have made it
more than six months for their fourth
dose or should they be taking the advice
of
uh dr rusin and maybe uh waiting until
those who uh
say are immunocompromised uh get theirs
thank you for that question and so the
nasty advice which has been uh really
simplified i would say and it's been
great um is that if you haven't had
a dose in six months you should get
another one
and the bivalent vaccine will be
come quite available i mean in very
reasonable amounts within the month of
september
and in the meantime of course if um if
if you're offered the current booster
uh you can still take that but but
within the month of september there
should be a good supply of the bivalent
vaccine
for the province and territories and
nazi doesn't take into account how many
previous boosters you've had is that
interval
um and if you it's been longer than six
months then go and get a boost
okay thanks for that and because it was
the reasoning then it was because um
a large fort dose campaign could have
delayed the receipt of a better vaccine
now
with this vaccine coming you're saying
that
no matter what the bivalent will be
available to all provinces that want it
that's correct and it would be as as
usual distributed in a uh as a matter of
principle a sort of per capital approach
um and but also the rate at which that
vaccine is being consumed will also be
taken into account given that we don't
want any wastage but maybe i'm just
trying to understand your question a
little bit better but some people i
think were worried that well if i just
got my dose in july
you know can i get another bivalent dose
and and people are worried about well
shouldn't we all wait until the bivalent
vaccine is available and i think and
nasi also
um you know
give that flexibility to the provinces
and territories
so that the interval can be
three months like if you had high risk
you got your
dose three months ago and the biovalent
vaccine is available you don't you
shouldn't be necessarily denying that
those you can have that flexibility
yeah that was thank you
uh thank you uh we've got one more
question on the line i don't know if the
minister uh has a moment for one more
question um i'm gonna open up the line
uh for one question no follow-up uh for
uh stephanie dubois from cbc edmonton
hi there um i'm just my question is
foreign minister isn't here but i'm
wondering if there was an additional
cost to canada to have the six million
doses of the medurana's original vaccine
converted to the ba1 uh bivalene vaccine
that was announced today
well to be certain uh you've got and you
deserve to to have that the right
information you will need and we will
help you
speak to my new colleague at pstc um
she will know exactly
the procurement process however what i
can tell you as dr thom said earlier yes
we have had a lot of flexibility in the
use of
the um
procurement contract that we have signed
so i expect
that flexibility also to be shared with
you when you speak to her office
thank you minister and thank you to the
doctors for joining us today we really
appreciate you taking our questions
thank you very much for your great work
dylan and everyone have a good day